usefic Bali feels safe in Tirana
although he never imagined ending up
there he fled the Taliban in Afghanistan
with his child and pregnant wife who'd
been a school teacher in Kabul they
reached the European Union via Greece
but he says Greek police stole their
possessions and harassed them so they
left the EU and crossed the border into
Albania I'm coming here in Albany is
good actually it's good country police
helped me I'm go to hospital with
ambulance some followers give it to me
and some clues for my daughter my babies
and my wife yeah she's a little help me
this is good country Youssef says he'll
remain in Albania for now but most
migrants and Asylum Seekers that arrive
in the country don't stay but pass
through it and other Balkan countries on
their way to EU member States including
Croatia Hungary and Austria a route that
the EU commission says is now the main
route for people arriving illegally in
the block the EU border agency frontex
says more than 120 000 Asylum Seekers
and migrants crossed into the EU via the
so-called Western Balkans route in 2022
that's 70 more than the previous year
and the highest number since 2016.
the increase says this migration expert
is partly due to deteriorating
conditions for Asylum seekers in Greece
and Turkey and the Fallout from the
covid crisis during the pandemic the
borders were closed so there is a was a
Slowdown of the movements and then it's
raised up again during this year and
especially the first nine months there
has been an increase of this number
Albania is never fully recovered from
decades under communist rule poverty and
Corruption are widespread and many
people migrate abroad for opportunities
for now the increase in Asylum Seekers
passing through the country hasn't
caused much public concern perhaps
because albanians often understand why
some people like Yusef feel they have to
leave home Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
Tirana Albania